[Music]
hello and welcome to AI the future of us
a podcast Style video series that
explores the ways in which AI is shaping
our future and how we can prepare for
the changes that lie ahead as developers
as people in cloud cloud Architects I'm
your host Priyanka vergaria and today we
are joined by janakiram msv who is
um an analyst In This Cloud industry and
space for quite some time thank you so
much for being here Jenny
thanks Priyanka it's my pleasure
amazing so let's kick this conversation
off with a little bit of background and
and your expertise in in cloud and in AI
sure so I spent a lot of time at
Microsoft about a decade followed by a
couple of years at AWS and for the last
decade or so I have been a one-man shop
primarily focused on Market Research
analysis and the evolution of cloud
and and how is AI part of this what have
you been
um doing so far in Ai and learning about
based on This research
um and where do you see this going
right so when AI was just picking up the
momentum uh a few years ago I think in
2014 2015 I realized cloud is going to
be the PowerHouse uh that will generate
the electricity uh sorry Android but if
you call AI is electricity I call Cloud
as the PowerHouse so I realized that is
going to be the logical home where a lot
of AI models are going to be generated
and trained so I started focusing on
that uh so I started my journey by
understanding what is machine learning
and how it is different from traditional
software development so initially I used
tools like Escalon which is psychic
learn and used managed cloud services
like you know Google Cloud ml engine
Azure ML and very early versions of
sagemaker I learned the basics and the
fundamentals of ml by just you know
looking at how this is becoming a
managed service offered by the
hyperscalers so it started from there
and today it has come to a point where
a lot of complex AI Based Services are
offered as apis you know you don't need
to know a lot of AI thanks to the
evolution of foundation models and
generative AI it is just becoming just
an API to consume but this API will
Empower and enable so many developers
and organizations to infuse the power of
AI into their applications
yeah so it's like you you talked about
electricity and the and the PowerHouse
and and powering that and and that's
kind of where if the the
basically Cloud lies right where a cloud
is going to be this uh this Powerhouse
of igniting all of these AI apis so that
not everybody has to be an expert in Ai
and ml but everybody can utilize Ai and
mo so sort of like democratizing the the
power of AI and ml
um with that uh what do you see as like
effective uses of AI
um in the cloud industry or just in tech
industry in general
right so AI is going to impact and
influence almost every vertical uh from
entry-level jobs you know like data
entry or converting Excel to PDF uh or
or uh you know just digitizing from
there all the way to very sophisticated
very Advanced SRE jobs AI is going to
influence almost every vertical and
every individual uh in this industry now
since I focus on more of operations and
specifically Cloud operations and devops
I'm seeing some interesting things that
are going to come up number one the
whole application of llms and GPT like
models for operations is going to be
revolutionary uh not just like
large language models are trained on
textual data and they're able to auto
complete and generate content imagine
training these llms with logs that are
generated by open source software
containers and and these logs are going
to be pretty standard you know whether
you run it in minicube or in a
multi-node cluster in gke the logs are
going to be the same the added messages
are going to be the same so imagine
training llms based on the observability
data coming from infrastructure
workloads and the supporting open source
software and then creating an automation
an agent driven automation that can not
only suggest what needs to be done but
can even remediate uh so that takes over
your escalation you know basically the
support escalation of L1 L to L3 and
llms will play a very powerful role in
analyzing the logs that come out
segregating them uh you know which is
basically classification and then trying
to remediate and only if they fail to
remediate it gets escalated to uh an SRE
you know who is responsible for the
uptime so this is going to impact the
way we do devops today uh all the way
from writing code to deploying it in
production and even day to operations so
this is going to be huge and significant
it is going to impact the devops uh
vertical and the overall Cloud
operations vertical significantly
that is such a great example it's also
like end-to-end use of of AI in in the
entire life cycle
um what are some of the because I this
also points to the skills that that we
would need to as individuals in this
devops ecosystem would need to either
possess or grow into so what it is what
are some of the key skills that
um that individuals should possess to be
successful in this AI driven world uh
maybe with that example or any other
example
right you know just like anything else
we are going to see two personas in this
ecosystem you know one Persona is
responsible for fine-tuning these
language models for infrastructure
uh they are very few uh you know they
understand how parameters work what is
fine tuning and how do we apply custom
data sets so that is going to be one
Persona and that's a very very uh unique
skill and uh a special skill to have you
know if you come from basic
understanding of fine tuning models and
if you know what is hyper parameter
tuning transfer learning and also
infrastructure that is the sweet spot
for you you are in a very unique place
to exploit you know this whole new
Revolution so that is basically the one
side of persona where you are training
the models and fine tuning models but
majority offers are going to be on the
other side where we consume this
so if you understand observability I
think uh you need to understand what is
prompt engineering and how do you feed
these observability data like Vlogs and
events to llms uh and how do you connect
the dots so that it not only you know
responds with auto completion and some
uh remediation techniques but how do you
connect the dots and what tools do you
need to close the loop uh for example
you know when uh your large language
model detects that uh the CPU
utilization is is at its brim and it
needs to add another node for example
now as an infrastructure engineer it's
your job to connect the dots and make
sure that you know you are able to add
one more node to the cluster or enable
horizontal power Auto scaling uh so so
that's that's where you know there is a
lot of opportunity uh converting the
responses given by generative AI into
more of actionable tasks and going for
advanced automation taking terraform
ansible and all your scripts to the next
level by connecting the dots so that is
a very unique skill so to summarize you
know there are two things one is fine
tuning these generative AI models for
infrastructure and observability data
and consuming those llms and connecting
them back to your automation pipelines
and scripting engine so that you are
basically getting into an autopilot mode
yeah and then in and maybe that that
second Persona is also responsible for
like taking uh the the data set that is
important to sort of sort of train this
model because the teams that will train
the models are ml experts they are not
the observability experts right so it
falls on you because the model is only
going to do as good as the data that you
provided so
um that that piece would also somehow
fall into the the expertise of of the
observability teams
um in this particular example so it this
is to also represent that uh any use
cases we we see evolve would require on
top of those foundational models would
require
um the expert experts in each of these
fields that we end up creating the
models for to to help make the models
better over time with uh the type of
data that that we need the rich data
sets that we need and then obviously the
expertise to sort of use those models
and consume them in the right way
um so thank you for that thank you yeah
so looking ahead of what do you believe
is the is the most exciting potential
application of AI
um that we have uh that we are yet to
see I I know you mentioned this devops
use case but
um anything more further like a stretch
like five ten years from now
oh that's too difficult to uh visualize
because things are moving so fast we
can't even predict what's what's coming
up in a quarter from now uh but but in
the near future what I actually
visualize is uh
you know aggregating uh multiple llms
and generative AI models to solve more
complex and advanced tasks
uh this is not specific to the AI Ops or
the devops automation that I mentioned
earlier but you know with generative AI
focusing on pretty much every type of
content you know like textual content
imagery content and video content uh
imagine the power of multi-modal uh
generative AI where you are able to feed
the output of one generative AI model to
another and ultimately get what you want
you know for example uh if you look at
e-commerce product managers when they
want to generate synthetic images that
are representing their product and they
need to write uh you know some kind of a
blurb or an abstract explaining their
product and also
do some quick competitive analysis uh
and and generate a 3D video now today
they have to use a variety of tools and
takes literally weeks or sometimes
months to come out uh with this output
that can go live on their website but
with generative AI uh the product
manager responsible for this queue will
be able to use one agent that will
orchestrate uh all these models
generative AI models responsible for
textual content imagery and visual video
content and will come out with a package
you know that he can straight away embed
in his website and that is going to be
significantly accelerating and making a
huge difference to you know product
managers who are responsible for
positioning their products
yeah and um we just launched this gen
um app builder which is
um sort of in that realm of like you
being able to create your own model
really quickly in the voice of let's say
your PR in your uh your legal terms and
then create this model and then start to
use it in campaigns for social media so
sort of that end-to-end story and it's
possible to do that super quickly I'm
also thinking about another use case
like let's say wanting to make Cloud
easier to use
um you're asking in chat like how do I
build a website just a super simple
example and then obviously it's a very
open-ended question there's like
multiple things that that the AI like
multi-turn AI conversation you're having
okay what kind of website do you want
what's the type of traffic amount of
amount of number of users where are they
going to be is it Global right all of
those parameters
um then lead to okay here's the type of
architecture that could work for your
website and then you end up saying no no
I've got a very small team and then
you're like okay yeah you got to go
serverless so like things like that
would seem like that whole multi-modal
um aspect of it was like here's a
picture then here's a documentation and
that's kind of where I see the future to
be even more exciting
um and I think we are not too far from
that which uh which is very which is
very very empowering so any last words
anything else you want to add about the
future of AI what are you excited about
anything else
yeah so you know just like cloud has
evolved and today we have large
hyperscalers with their own apis and
their own protocols uh what I'm very
excited about is how these Investments
coming from the hyperscalers would
change the world particularly uh you
know the the devops and the cloud
operations uh model I am visualizing a
world where we are going to see agents
uh that are going to be orchestrating
the prompt engineering uh and
fine-shuning and all of that which will
become the front end you know just like
you have kubernetes as an orchestrator
orchestrating a set of containers llms
are going to be huge and we are going to
see agents that are going to be
specialized for individual verticals
that will act as a front end and will
negotiate with the back end llms and gen
AI models to do what is appropriate and
what is specific to the end user so
we'll see uh this this evolution of
Agents taking over and become the
orchestrators of multimodal deployments
in in between all of that like so llms
would make the natural language part of
it more easy but then also the back end
part of it more easy and on in including
all this we would need this middle layer
of like the apis or the middleware that
will actually make things happen so if I
said
stop this virtual machine when things
like this happen
um then the ability to stop the virtual
machine is through like this middleware
uh but the llm is behind it and in front
of it so to understand the Lang natural
language and then also understand the uh
the operations piece of it
um it's quite it's going to be very
exciting thank you so much for joining
us today Johnny
um it has been incredibly insightful to
hear your thoughts on the impact and the
effective use of AI
um we really look forward to seeing how
AI will continue and shape our world in
clouds and just in general
um so stay tuned
absolutely thanks for having me I
thoroughly enjoyed this conversation
thank you
[Music]